starting pitcher for the diamondbacks
tonight the 23 year old right hander
roberto castigano's eight appearances
for the diamondbacks tonight's just his
second career big league start
and adobe lines one into right field
that's gonna be a a one-hop off the wall
and it kicks away from paving smith and
o'doubles around second heading to third
and he's gonna get there a head first
slide
a leadoff triple his second of the
season
that one gets away and it's going to go
back to the screen and the phils will
get a run it'll be a pass ball for
carson kelly his fifth of the year and
the phillies lead it one nothing yeah
they'll face ranger suarez and ranger
his fourth start of the year he's five
and three
bouncer back toward the middle gregorius
scoops it behind the second base bag
throws to first
one out
that's a fair ball by therias and down
the line
as drooble takes the turn and he's in at
second with a two-round double
and the 1-0 swing and a bouncer left
side cut off by the reyes moving to his
left he almost went to tag cabrera
instead he'll throw to first and that'll
do it for the diamondbacks
o2 pitch
that's a hot shot through the hole on
the left side of base hit a quick bat
there brown mccutchen matianos they had
one and two this is where he's made some
mistakes
ahmed the only guy over there they get
one and they roll it
fly ball left center field
oh double on the run and he's there
able to track it down says hello to some
fans
[Applause]
rojas unbelievable
just rolls it into right field a two out
singles
ellis drives it to center herrera will
have to play it on the hop
rojas little stutter step coming around
second
back to back two out singles
well here's castillanos who does not
have a hit but does have an rpi
i've got to tell you i was watching
video of him today and he looked like he
knew what he was doing rojos is around
third heading for home the throw to the
plate and he is
out at home plates you think he ran
through that stop sign oh my
i mean that was
that wasn't even close it's on the turf
first of all
and he hit it hard but it went to harper
so quickly
and then bryce
it was kind of a comfortable swing
there's a base runner that should have
been it out so right to your in max
point
lead off man aboard
a walk and a hit batter open up the
diamond back third
oh one pitch grounded towards short
backhanded by dede the second for one
over to first in time
[Applause]
and rolls away here comes nick and we're
tied
change up in the dirt reel muto couldn't
corral it and it's one to one
and he shoots it the other way there's a
base hit for gene segura and that's why
the slumps don't last
too long for gene because his ability to
use the whole field
and it toward the left field corner
rojas on the move
and josh runs it down
walker sends it to right center and that
gets down and rolls to the wall
christian walker a one out double
[Applause]
swag in a miss
you got him to go fishing
is going to finish off the strikeout
well with the pitcher spot behind drew
ellis they'll give him the free pass
and work to castiano
bounced up the middle and throw into
center crew is way off line walker's
home and the diamondbacks grab the lead
roberto castellanos two for two
well he didn't get an rbi the first time
he made sure he got it there
that's an eagle eye by brad miller good
night ted
tied him up with a big floating curve
ball
and castianos gets his first strikeout
ball four ranger suarez works out a walk
and the phillies have two on
herrera launches it deep to right field
pavon smith has got just enough room
castillanos got away with that one
gave up two ounces in a run in the
fourth or two hits in a run in the
fourth and there's a lead-off walk to
cattell
in the fifth
and behind that there wasn't much else
as drooble knocks it into left field
good start to the fifth so here's carson
over two he's grounded out twice first
and second no outs
that one gets through between thereas
and gregorius here comes martay
mccutchen's throw is just a little late
and it's 3-1 diamondbacks cabrera gets
third base and carson's in its second
[Applause]
there's another base on balls
second walk in this inning fourth of the
ball game for ranger suarez
[Applause]
not the corner a little too close to
take that time corey blazer
brings him up on a borderline pitch well
connor brockton is on to try to get this
last out just keep this at a two run
game three balls two strikes
and a high fly ball out towards shallow
center field segura is out oh doubles in
herrera makes the call and the catch and
the beginning
[Applause]
sky high near the line
as drooble
[Applause]
caleb's had a good slider going tonight
gets his first strikeout lined up by
smith on the next one torreya swings
there's a ground ball to shore ahmed's
got it nick fires the first to walk or a
one two three for caleb smith
is smashed into center
and he's hit for pavement against the
left-hander
walker doubled and scored in the fourth
he walked in the fifth one for two
walker trying to drop it into right
harper
has got it on a hop here's the throw
pavement's in there and it's four to one
and walker's got the rvi
[Applause]
big wingspan 3-2
got him
that's five straight retired by caleb
smith his second strikeout here's odubal
and the pitch
oh double sends one of the air to right
field pavon smith is going back and this
one is gone
herrera gave it a bid his last time up
but he hit it to the fence this time he
gets it over the fence
his ninth home run of the year
and it's back to a two-run game it's
four to two
crew chief tom hallian with caleb
smith's glove caleb is in danger of
failing a foreign substance inspection
here they took the glove
they're gonna keep the glove and it
looks like he's been thrown out
so this is significant because as we
said you that's your one man down for
the next 10 games
as tyler clifford is into his 11th ball
game
and the pitch
swing at a miss he got him with 89 miles
an hour and somehow some way the
diamondbacks have taken the first two
games of this series against the fills
[Applause]
[Music]